PROFESSOR: Our subject today
then is Fermi's golden rule.
So that's what we're
going to develop.
Fermi's golden rule.
And this has to do with
the study of transitions.
And typically, the interesting
and sophisticated thing
about this subject
is that you have
a transition from
some initial state
to a state that is part
of a continuum of states.
That's what makes
it complicated.
The transition from
one discrete state
to another discrete
state with a perturbation
is kind of a simple
matter to do.
But when you can go
into a continuum,
you have to integrate over
the set of final states,
and that makes it a
lot more interesting.
So we go from a discrete
state into a continuum.
And that makes it
somewhat challenging.
So we will consider
this in two forms.
It's worth considering
the case of what
we call constant perturbations.
And you might say,
well, aren't we
doing time dependent
perturbation theory?
Yes, we are.
But this kind of
perturbation, you
will think of it as saying
that H is H0 plus a V that
is time independent.
But the way we think of
it is that here is time,
here is time 0, and here is V.
V turns on at time equals 0.
So there's a little
bit of time dependence.
There was no V
before time equals 0,
and there is a V
after time equals 0.
So it's almost like the
Hamiltonian changes.
And we want to see what
transitions we get.
Because always the subject is
the subject of transitions.
And we will see an application
of this later today.
The other case is what is
called a harmonic perturbation,
in which H is equal
to H0 plus delta H.
And delta H is going
to be harmonic.
2H prime.
That's conventions
to put a 2 in there.
It's convenient.
Times cosine omega t.
And this will be for
t between 0 and t0.
Sorry if some people
can't see this.
Too far to the right.
2H prime cosine of omega t
when t is between 0 and t0.
And it's 0 otherwise.
And H prime, of course, is
time independent as well.
Time independent.
So these are the
two main cases when
we will consider transitions.
And we'll do the first one
in a lot of detail today.
The subject is trying to get
the transitions understood
for this case.
And after that,
next time, we will
do the case of the
harmonic perturbation that
brings in a few new issues.
But then, all of the
rest is the same.
So once you've understood how
to do the constant transition,
the harmonic perturbation
is going to be easier.
So constant
perturbations will be
useful to understand, for
example, the phenomenon
of auto-ionization.
Some atoms sometimes
ionize spontaneously,
and this has to do
with this subject.
Harmonic perturbations has to
do with even a more popular
subject, which is atoms
interacting with radiation.
You send in an
electromagnetic field.
That is a harmonically
varying perturbation,
and that's going to allow
you to calculate transitions.
And by the time
we're done with this,
you will be experts in
calculating atomic transitions.
So one subject we
need since we're
going to be doing transitions
between a discrete state
or continuum is to
describe the continuum.
And for that, for
the continuum, we
use the concept of a density
of states in the continuum.
Now, we will be considering
momentum eigenstates.
And the momentum,
you know very well
the momentum of a free
particle is a continuum.
Takes absolutely
continuous values.
So there is no way
you can count them
or you can tell how many
there are per momentum range.
It's like saying how many
numbers are there from 0 to 1.
The way you have
to do that always
is by adding an
extra parameter you
wish you didn't have to add.
And that's kind of
things that we have
to do in physics sometimes.
We have to add parameters.
You consider when we discussed
last time the delta function
perturbation, we broadened it,
and we were able to calculate.
And then we saw that
the broadening size
didn't matter for the
result. Therefore, good.
So here, we'll do the same.
You know that the
momentum eigenstates
of a particle in an interval
or in a circle are quantized.
And then you can count
quantized states.
So we will put the
whole world in a box.
A big box.
Size of the galaxy, size of the
Earth, size of the laboratory
maybe is big enough.
And we'll put this parameter l
there for the size of the box.
And we will get the
density of states
because now the
states can be counted.
Afterwards, by
the time we're all
done with the transition rates
of the Fermi's golden rule,
we hope that length
is going to disappear.
So that's something
we will see that it
happens in calculations.
And there will be good
reasons why it happens.
So we'll put the
world in a big box.
It's not that big
the way I draw it,
but it's supposed
to be very big.
Length l.
And you think of the
quantization of momentum
by considering a wave function
that would be normalized
and has--
it's a momentum eigenstate.
It has momentum in the x
direction, y direction,
and z direction.
And that wave function,
if all the sides
of this world, this cubical
world with length l,
that wave function is
properly normalized.
You square it, and the norm is
equal to 1 times this factor
squared.
You integrate it.
It's all good.
So this is a nice
wave function in which
the integral psi squared V
cubed x over the box is 1.
And then what else do we do?
We decide that we have to
consider periodic boundary
conditions.
Well, think of it as a
torus, properly speaking,
in which each
direction is a circle.
So the wave function
repeats itself
after x increases by l,
after y increases by l,
or after z increases by l.
You could have chosen a box with
a finite big wall at the end.
It would make no
difference for the counting
at the end of the day.
So the conditions are
that kx multiplied by l
should be a multiple
of nx 2 pi times nx,
ky times l, 2 pi times
ny, kz times l, 2 pi nz.
And therefore, the
total number of states
can be calculated by taking
a little differential
of this thing.
We say, well, if we let
kx vary by a little bit,
dkx from this equation times
l is 2 pi dnx dky times l,
2 pi times dny, and dkz
times l is 2 pi times dnz.
So if I were to consider a
little interval of momentum
defined by dkx, dky, dkz, a
little cube in momentum space,
the number of
states in this cube
would be dn, which
is dnx, dny, dnz.
And this is equal to l over 2 pi
cubed d cubed k, which is dkx,
dky, dkz.
I say, if in this momentum range
the quantum number nx contains
this number of values,
dnx, the quantum number ny
can take a set of values, and
the same for the quantum number
in the z direction.
The total set of quantum
numbers is the product of them.
So there is that many
states in this little cube
of momentum space--
that is, momentum space
that is between some
k and a little more, called dk.
Well, that's a famous formula.
And the n is equal to l
over 2 pi cubed d cubed k.
Some people know this by heart.
But now we want to
write this in the terms
of a density of states
as a function of energy.
So if this is the
number of states
in some interval
in momentum space,
I can try to convert
this into saying,
well, all these states,
because the momentum is varying
within some little
bounds, the energy
is varying within
some little bounds.
So let's figure out
how much the dE is.
And then the total
number of states
will be given in this
range by the number
of states per unit energy
multiplied by this thing.
So this is the density
of states, which
is states per unit energy.
And many times, this is the
quantity we really want.
We have here an
energy E as well.
So we think of this V
cubed k as a little cube
in momentum space.
If momentum space
has an origin here,
you can imagine states with
some momentum, and then
a little cube in here saying
how much the momentum varies.
So all these states
have some momentum
and vary a little
bit in the momentum.
Therefore, they all
basically have some energy
up to some little variation.
So how do we connect
these two things?
Well, you remember, E is equal
to h squared k squared over 2m.
And how about d cubed k?
We'll try to think of d cubed
k physically as all the states
that have momentum k.
And now, this is a
space diagram now.
This is x, y, and z.
So here are the states
with momentum k.
They point in this direction.
So this is the direction
the states are pointing.
And now we think of them as
having some possible angle
here.
d omega.
So this is the direction.
So let me not say
they're x, y, and z.
Let me use angles here.
Theta and phi, representing
the azimuthal and polar angle
of this direction.
So we have a little range
here and a little range
of magnitude of momentum.
So let me see if I can
draw it kind of nicer.
You can imagine a
little cone as it grows,
and the last part is a little
thick piece of the cone here
of thickness dk.
So d cubed k is the volume
of that little pillbox here.
And it's k square
d omega times dk.
So that's d cubed k.
And now to relate
it to the energy
we have here, this equation.
So we take a differential.
And it's d energy is
h squared kdk over m.
So d cubed k here is k
dk, k d omega times k vk,
and this is the same k dk here.
So we can write it as k d omega.
And for k dk we have m
over h squared d energy.
So we're almost done
with our computation.
We go back to this equation.
And we have rho of E dE,
or dn, is equal to l over
2 pi cubed d cubed k.
But now we have
what d cubed k is.
It's m over h
squared k d omega dE.
So this is our formula.
And this is rho of E dE.
And here, for example,
you have rho of E.
Actually, if it were rho of E,
I should have here k expressed
in terms of E. Just makes the
formula a little more messy.
But if you think of it as
a function of the energy,
you have to say
the words properly.
What is rho of E?
Rho of E is the density
of states per unit energy,
but when you're
only counting states
that have a momentum
within an angle d omega.
So this is the density of
states per unit energy,
because this gives you states.
So this must be states
per unit energy.
But you're only looking
at the states that
are within an angle d omega.
If you were to look at the
density of all states that
have energy E, you would
have to integrate over omega.
But many times, we want
to make a transition.
You have an atom
and you're sending
an electromagnetic wave.
And you want to
make a transition,
and you want to see how
many electrons, for example,
are kicked out in
some direction.
So you need the density of
states within some solid angle.
So this is a
relatively useful thing
to have, not to integrate,
so that you can keep control
over your states and orient
them at a given angle.
So we've done a little
bit of basic preparation.
We've said what the Fermi
golden rule aims to do,
and it requires transition
to the continuum where we'll
have to use density of states.
And here is an example
of how you calculate
the density of states.